[Music]  my chest hair isn't black  i dyed it yeah everyone knows  good morning whitlock let's grab today  by the horns  you just hit me with an apple yeah  feel free to leave my class at any time  for any reason  my sex ed condoms came oh and looks like  i ordered enough to get the free dildo  have a nice day stop having those  delivered to school  i just got snagged this is crazy  oh my god stop no no no no don't stand  up there  guys we got to think bigger okay i want  to hurt this old lady without killing  anybody  you know has that been super clear that  that we don't kill the person  it's definitely good to hear out loud  have you guys texted your friends about  buying some cocaine i'm not going down  for this  [Music]  damn can we swear now i think so holy sh  don't call it a comeback  you